العاصفه الوثائق السريه المسربه لم تهدا
بعد واصداؤها لا تزال تصلح في العديد من
بقاع العالم وبعيدا عن الجدال المصار حول
كيفيه التسريب فان النقاش يدور ايضا حول
احتماليه ان يكون التسريب مجرد مناوره في
اطار ما يسمى بحرب المعلومات في اخر ردود
الفعل على هذه التسريبات اعتبرت موسكو ان
الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه قد تدخل ضمن
حمله تضليل من جانب الولايات المتحده بهدف
خداع روسيا وعلق نائب وزير الخارجيه
على الموضوع قائلا ان تسريب قد يكون مزيفا
ومتعمدا من جانب واشنطن من جهته قال
المتحدث باسم الكرملين روسيا لا تعرف في
هذه المرحله مدى صحه هذه الوثائق
كيف بدورها حاولت عدم اعاره اهتمام كبير
لهذه الوثائق حيث صرح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
ان الوثائق المسربه ما هي الا مزيج من
الصدق والكذب على حد قوله لافتا الى انها
صبت لمصلحه روسيا وحلفائها كما نفى
ريزنكوف صحه وجود قوات من حلف النيتو في
اوكرانيا كما اشارت الى ذلك الوثائق
بدورها اعترضت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
على دقه المعلومات الوارده في الوثائق
المسربه بعدما اشارت احداها الى ان نحو
خمسين من افراد القوات الخاصه البريطانيه
متواجده حاليا في اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات